[Music]
thank you for standing up my job it's
great to be here thank you so much I
appreciate it thanks everybody just
gonna say thanks for five minutes I
think that having kids is like doing
drugs because it's not for everybody you
got to be in the right mindset it costs
a lot of money there's peer pressure
involved and it could ruin your life
like those are some of the possibilities
like I haven't had kids but I've done
drugs and I recommend drugs to more
people and I recommend kids like I think
we've all seen people with kids and
thought you should have been drugs
instead that have been better for
everybody we've never seen a person on
drugs and thought kids would be the
answer right that's a I didn't I never
do that many drugs I just started
smoking pot when I was 24 didn't even
like it people hear that sometimes are
like boo you're like pot boo which is a
weirdly aggressive way to be pro
relaxation
maybe you're yelling at somebody for
doing pot wrong I feel like you're also
doing pot wrong like some people they
don't do drugs but they haven't done
most of the drugs Riley did one which is
like saying don't eat foods you only
have one food like I had a sweet pickle
we're not gonna enjoy eating you know I
mean like I tried baby corn grow up you
know what I mean like I don't you can't
judge a whole category based on one
element of the category you can't watch
one Nicolas Cage movie and then decide
every movie must be amazing right you
can't do that that guy has made a number
of enjoyable movies you know how I did
it he made a much larger number of total
movies like if you have a million
monkeys working on a million typewriters
they will come up with Conair and face
off before they get to Shakespeare
that's definitely true
check the discard pile oh that's nice of
you
you're nice everyone's nice Nicolas Cage
Academy Award winner they can't take
that away from him
much as anyone might like to it's not
like an old man's driver's license for
like hey you used to be good at this we
are gonna need that back now though you
are hurting people with your vehicles so
one of my favorite kinds of movies is
the twist and turn variety like twister
or Turner and hooch and I have a new
buddy cop movie between a tornado and a
dogs called twister and hooch the twist
is that hooch is the tornado twisters
the dog not important but usual suspects
one of the first twist ending movies
ever saw blown away at the end didn't
even know I was supposed to be I don't
know as a mystery like it was a mystery
to me that it was a mystery if you're
like what kind of movies this would be
like it's a mystery oh it's a mystery I
don't know I don't know I'm talking
about you know maybe like I was blown
away those movies are great there you
feel dumb but and you're happy because I
got ignorant bliss thanks I don't get it
every once in a while you see one of
these movies you get to the end of the
movie and you figured it out you
actually every step of the way you're
like oh I think I see you're not gonna
trick me a movie you want me to think
that is actually this you feel real good
about yourself every step every plot
twists predicting what's gonna happen
you're so proud of yourself to get to
the big to a surprise finale at the end
revealing you already saw that movie
once and forgot about it so turns out
one time I sell one of those twist
ending movies twist at the end turned
out to be it had been written and
directed by M night Shyamalan I was like
twist ending of that joke is I turned
out to be Aziz Ansari I like him too so
the point is don't do drugs cuz they'll
make you forget movies and also your
original point so here's why I don't
like pot pot best-case scenario makes me
go to sleep which I can do by myself
everyday don't need you pot worst-case
scenario makes me forget every sentence
that I'm in the middle of well in the
middle of the sentence that I'm in the
middle of while I'm in the middle of the
sentence like here's me I'm pot at a
party like will you say again the thing
that you just said and then I'll know I
started to say the thing that I just
said you go first then I'll go first you
first than me first why are you not
going are you not my friend are you a
cop am i a cop
is anyone a cop you're a cop they're cop
anywhere a cop cop Old MacDonald was a
cop ie ie FIFO are you an undercover cop
am I an undercover cop
Am I so far undercover I had to get high
to prove to you I'm not undercover but I
got so high that I forgot I was
undercover is my undercover over what's
the over-under on whether my undercover
is over are you an overcomer cop is that
a Robocop am i aerobic anaerobic at high
that's me on pot every time into a
mirror you don't say like how did you
know
I know you're in play how did you okay
cut here nah let's just shake on it
ow ow ow that's why I don't like pot cuz
it hurts my fingers it is still better
than kids though surprise ending thanks
a lot everybody
you